my name is Rainbow Rambo no rain
today you're going to from a line of
women guess how many people each of them
have slept with
okay how are you gonna go about this I
mean I'm a bit of a player so I might be
able to sniff out a fellow hoe remember
this guy
you got a whole baby it's back remember
this guy did he really come out here and
have a bit of a player loosen maybe he
is maybe he got game we don't know we
don't know my suspicion yeah I don't
think he's much of a player
I think you get play
but I don't think you're much of a
player
being a player
to know some idea of smoothness
some [__] ain't got it here's a list
[Music]
300. this is really awkward
initial thoughts
some are cute
okay
if you're really trying to Mac on women
and you see a group of women the last
thing you do is tell the group of women
some of y'all attractive only to say
some of y'all aren't
the reason being is women got to just
find a [__] [__] Alliance where if
you insult one of their friends like
that they gonna bang together to hate
your ass even if they liked you at the
beginning they're not friends though
it'll even matter
the [__] Alliance is not about
friendship
you know what it is about
it's about having a party
women will 100 band together in a group
like that when there's dude involved
against the one guy sure hi what's your
name my name is sapphire Sapphire do you
have an only fans yeah
what is her physical appearance give you
what kind of box
uh
ferociously attractive yeah is that okay
he sounds like please HR don't fire me
um sorry
um what were you asking
how often do you color your hair maybe
two or three months a girl that changes
up her hairstyle pretty often usually
indicates some underlying stuff
uh
you got somebody in there yeah
is there somebody in there Hey listen
listen there's a bunch of red flags here
she showed up to a body count event with
a whole baby inside her how's that red
flag I think this girl is 50. that's
what I'm gonna give her just for that
this will be my third and fourth babies
are you more comfortable because you
know I'm pregnant
you know I'm used to more used to being
around
women who are clearly committed already
committed to making babies or what part
of me yeah okay I'm sorry are your other
two children from the same dad no okay
now I've made you angry I'm sorry
um
[Laughter]
everything even comfortable with
everything wow this guy's terrified of
being canceled poor guy I don't think
it's the side I think he's tired from
being canceled by his wife yeah even
though he came in jeans I think you're
wearing her thong I'm not gonna lie how
many baby daddies you got three okay so
you like
50. I rest my case 50. I rest my case
50. I was a relationship with your
father it's really good
you go into all the goddamn stereotypes
yeah I think he likes being a villain
yeah ladies that don't have a great
relationship with either parents they
get around a little bit more I'm gonna
go with the 16. what kind of point do
you watch CNC what's CNC uh consensual
non-consent that's great stop
was great consensual non-consensual is
like
a grape yeah great yeah that's that's
like yeah that's what I said oh I heard
that's great I said [__] well no I said
great oh
you got great again [__] stop saying
that great
I'm not gonna lie maybe I was wrong did
y'all not hear it that's great no that's
great
hey you know I understand why I
understand why you heard great yeah but
I said great
but it's all consensual okay
he's like no I'm scared no apparently
those fantasies are super cool yes yes
very super common I've actually had a
girlfriend who said that to me and I
said okay
that's gonna stay in fantasy what you
think
I'm gonna just try this on the off
change that you do enjoy the reality
what if you get second thoughts hell no
no there's too many no no officer she
wanted me to force me are you a lesbian
no dress
yeah
you see when he asked why do I think
that he was not asking himself he was
why do I bang that girl yeah you said
you said it to her sometimes it better
if it comes from you
good we're on the same page
why do I think that yeah
you're wearing the same page okay you
seem well put together you don't give
off like post hoe Vibes I'm gonna go
with nine nine 300 plus this is not okay
I I still love me after giving you I'm
not offended
imma give her like she's either 75 300.
00 she did all
in Greece the Spartans she [__] them
all yes she did yes she did Leonidas I
don't think she did no no
not 300. but how many of the Spartans
did she [__] the ones who died in the
movie
make sure she send them off to work good
they all died with two people man
300.
let's go at least I didn't say she
[__] the whole Persian army because
that's disrespectful yeah there was
elephants in there
laughs
that's why oh and the tall [__] with
the chain yeah if you [__] him you
know he got STD yeah the [__]
that put his hand on Leonidas oh what
brings you here tonight let's see
what brings you here tonight
the delay on me here the answer because
I'm like God damn tennis that's what
that's what she did though she showed up
in a skirt and no she showed up in the
skirt
she looks really innocent but then she
look like she ain't it's the titties out
for me
my [__] he knows everything is really
hard out it's the titties out for me
either I buy things that are really
useless or you could buy some things
that are very useful in my daily routine
of looking good and smelling good I
perfume myself but sometimes my perfume
game is really something to it's really
hard to upkeep yeah because the perfume
they range from 150 to 300 and sometimes
I want to try new stuff and I don't know
what to try well I got the thing for you
if you click on the link below and
they're going to be able to send you
different smells this week they sent me
a month supply of Dolce and Gabbana that
was
never gonna try that Dolce Gabbana but I
gotta tell you it's really good look at
this that's a usual sample they send you
this is what they sent you
oh I got the initial by Paragon and I
have the Jew signature uh Viva La Juicy
Noir and they have high-end Brands like
Prada Gucci Versace as well as a variety
of high-end fragrances that you can
choose from Sandberg click on the link
below and you're going to be able to
save 55 off your first month that's like
seven dollars for your first purchases
come on guys like what are you doing get
your smell on you know that's the key to
get the ladies
if you're a little older I maybe ask for
your number but still too young yeah
yeah you're pretty old
they don't you're right they don't like
no they don't like him they they chose
he not player no like I said there's
talent and there's hard workers you
ain't got this you said you know what
you know what man you're a wizard out
sometimes sometimes I forget you're a
wizard my dude no it's just like that
I'll get everything from the outfit to
how he talks like do you just know it
ain't it and he hasn't demonstrated
anything in the first six minutes of
this video that showed me he got it true
and the fact he said I'm I'm a I'm a
player
oh it turned off if you gotta say it it
probably ain't true yes stretch
I mean I'll ask what's her body count
zero you think first zero not with them
titties I refuse to believe that I think
she gotta she gotta have one of them low
numbers I would have given her two you
saw me in a bar setting or maybe at the
club
how would you approach me I would make
eye contact
stare at the lips make them feel nervous
stare back at the eyes and then look
away and then if they want to come this
is the classic [__] 10 meter away
distance you should pick up that I want
you guys don't get that
thank you
okay I hate this approach one I think
it's really a whack two I can tell you
that [__] works that [__] Works 100 I
refuse to believe that this guy's been
in a nightclub and seen that [__] happen
and said it don't work because it 100
Works dudes will run up on an attractive
woman even if she never looks their way
if she making eye contact and licking
the lips and then looking away with a
little cute smile 100 dudes are running
up on anybody who've been in a nightclub
environment knows that [__] works it's
unfortunate because I hate it but I
agree it does function guys don't get
that you don't
you see all the way all the girls are
laughing at you
they don't like you I'm just like
I'm gonna just give you two thank you
just the what you're giving off what I'm
giving it doesn't give off a high number
you know what's killing me is that
normally saying a low number for a girl
would be seen as a good thing but the
way that girl you read that right I'm
telling you he's losing the room I know
because I normally like [__] I don't
even he's losing me so I can tell he's
losing the room my name is Rainbow Rambo
no
oh
[Music]
hey
Oh my days that's a crazy name I think
she said rainbow yeah she said rainbow
she clearly said rainbow Rambo imma give
that to you brother that was actually
funny was that a Content name my mom
literally just named me rainbow oh I
love it how old are you I'm 19. oh [__]
I think you might be that defy
expectations type of person
[__] uh you're a [__] what numbers you
giving them
left to right yeah 15
30 70. 2 300 zero
do you think the 18 got 300
300 zero and the 18 year old got 300
[__] what the [__]
a 300 318 you know how many that is a
year 300
God damn okay no not 300 a year I mean
yeah she could be [__] so since she
was 15 or [__] I'm gonna go left to
right so I'm gonna give her 30 70 yeah
50 here
sixteen two nine I don't think anybody
got 300 of this one if anyone got 300 I
would say it's this girl right here
she's the only one I could see shots
yeah because of the age
yeah also just something somebody will
throw me off a bit but yeah
nobody yeah
yes something about her gave me like
BDSM or some [__] like that yeah or she
been in the game she been working
just one I'm gonna have everyone swap
their number okay
foreign
I guess that she was freaky and I
guessed her 70 yeah I put two on her and
then I put nine on her you're a virgin
wow wow
what card you won't guard there uh the
300 I mean that's that's impressive
somebody I don't even have this is my
natural hair color and I like my dad
really like to [__]
agreed
you see how they're low-key calling him
out that was not Loki no she laid it in
front of him yeah she's like
I went through like a period where like
I just kind of wanted to like have a
roster of pretty boys and then
occasionally it was like girls I just
had a lot of fun in my 20s I love that
with men and women does this number
surprise you a little bit I guess yeah
you're attracting attention with the
your your the way you dress
uh
let's see what she says you're you're
the way you dress does that mean she
wants to have sex
oh no it just raises her pots like don't
be trying to make this dude seem weird
like if you coming out in a burqa I'm
probably gonna think you probably got
less bodies than a girl with her titties
and a thong
is that a hot take it doesn't mean I
know it doesn't mean it's just races his
likelihood Jesus Christ it's fine
you know like ladies get scared of a
dude when he's walking behind you late
at night do I come I'll be like it
doesn't mean but it raises the odd so
what do you count as body count I just
don't count oil okay it's gonna be hot
okay
they were trying to make her out seem
like she cleaned turns out she been
sucking a mad dick out in the back
activities
even personality
and they wrap around they did no no no
listen listen she said she been giving
enough dude's top that's weird to me
that's not weird that's weird that you
gave mad talk to [__] but never that's
weird no it's not weird why it's not
weird but it happens more often than you
think okay she said that's like a lot of
dick okay well the only thing I say no
to is like the sex part because I never
want to regret it can be something you
regret for real so it's not even about
the parental religion it's regret that
is weird
that is weird you out here giving tops
to dude you out here doing all that
stuff but then the penetration that's
weird because people really thinking
that it's not sex it's really
dissociated from sexual activity it's
just a thing especially the new the new
generation that we have here they be
giving tops high five
what do you mean they'd be giving them
yeah that's what they be before they
have their first before they have their
their first penetration experience they
be that's what they be doing they don't
consider something out of prison
preservation sex so they will they will
engage in that why does she call it oral
sex then
because that's what it's called but it's
really weird the way it it's really
weird but a lot of people oral sex even
there even if there's a world sex in it
I don't even think they believe that you
wanted me to tell you why because if
they was in a relationship with somebody
and then they found out that person gave
oral sex to somebody else they would see
that as sexually cheated because
I want to be cheating the young the
younger generation and you talk about 25
and under yeah whatever they're talking
about intercourse right there's a
hierarchy of intercourse and top is
there's fingering pop and the rest of it
you understand what I'm saying and
that's it like it doesn't count it
doesn't count it doesn't count as
anything except what we talk about of
course if you have a relationship with
someone and then you give talk to
someone else you're being intimate with
that person so but the top thing they
really don't consider there's
penetration and top the top thing they
don't really consider what as a sexual a
sexual thing like the only thing
consider it as the first time or a
sexual thing it's like it's sexual but
it's not that deep has uh how is our
I'll put it okay all right let us know
what you guys think in the comments you
gave me 300. I know you had like a few
left it was uh 83 you could have given
me 83. you guessed pretty well for me
okay the job I have most people guess a
lot higher so are you in sales or what
what kind of
it's like Hooters it's called Twin Peaks
but it's a little bit more clever Twin
Peak I get it
all right well that's it for today's
video let us know what you guys think
what do you guys think about the numbers
were you surprised by any of it you
would have guessed the Virginia one of
them but I mean I think I did a day well
no you guessed 300. I said two but then
you said zero then you went to 300. you
went from nothing Mr [__] you [__]
the whole cast zero to 300 really yeah
yeah yeah yeah you went you went you
went far then I went 50 but whatever
yeah but there you go you're not always
psychic sometimes we get them wrong but
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you
Penn bird click on the link below and
you're going to be able to save 55 off
your first month that's like seven
dollars for your first purchases come on
guys like what are you doing get your
smell on you know that's the key to get
the ladies
all right